there is Andy welcome sir Andy you have
about you have about 300 people here in
New York watching and then the live
audience as well which is watching via
for TV so thank you very much for
joining our health conference how are
things our things in Valley well before
I report on that I was wondering if you
got any thoughts about applying the
teacher qualification that is coming to
elementary schools and apply it to
people who go to conferences on any of
the new subjects like big data before
they leave give them a test
we we certainly should especially since
it is a conference about numbers so yeah
that's a great idea that is there there
will be a pop quiz at the end thats
Sarah so so Andy I don't know people
here probably don't know but the reason
we we were able to kind of join forces
with you and this was because in the
issue of wire that's going to be the
stands next week could appear in your
mailbox is now you you have an essay
that you wrote a manifesto in sorts like
call to arms for reform in the health
care industry and you call for not not
radical transparency but just some
amount of transparency on on price first
of all so that that story is is live
today on wired com on our website but i
just wanted to maybe start off by by
lettering letting you channel the the
vitriol that you had in the in the essay
and and kind of let our audience here
know about what what your idea is for
for health care if there was virtually
in it it was very dilute it has taken me
quite a number of exposures to realize
that any bill charge or any financial
action taken toward me as an individual
was never anything like what it said on
that paper and i started asking
questions about it i have friends in the
health care business and they are
prominent professors but I had the
question book do you understand
what your charges mean it is not
hospitalization this like a diagnostic
test no how could I the same people are
devoted to lowering the cost of medical
care picture this in my prior life were
spent measuring chips investing money in
a treatment process to lower the cost of
those hips or increase the performance
of it and picture the scene that
somebody would come to me we need to
have a deep UV in photolithography and
all it costs is two hundred million
dollars in development and about 30
billion dollars a machine i would say
how do you know and i would get a look
ranging from why do you ask such a
stupid question or trust me
or none of those because I would be too
chicken where the question what impact
would have had this kind of behavior
under chip industry conversely how can
we go after medical costs when in a
particular situation will try to find a
cost analysis course come on the scene
university of california berkeley and
UCSF you can we could not find such a
course this is part of your tryn the
translational medicine program they use
jess's and so there's no there's no way
to bart the song right and there's no
effort to to promote transparency even
even in that forum well if you are a
professor I have a choice of teaching
something that has textbooks exercises
residence training modules or have none
of those things what are you at each
it's a reinforcing of teaching what we
have no measures of more importantly no
understanding and even more importantly
I am suspicious that the situation
prevails because it is in the commercial
interest of members of the healthcare
comic community so this is you you do
mention in the in the essay that you
wrote about the you're concerned about
the insurers and the consolidation in
the in the among insurers that is is
actually going the opposite way from
transparency
they have they have less and less
interest in sharing what costs are as
they as they become larger players and
consolidation is that that put your
point that I got a report first of all
the consolidation toward larger players
is of significant concern in most
industries the US government has lost
that the execute in the form of the
Justice Department or the FTC have a
person experience in death and that
those laws got love it out of the
federal domain states can do them the
federal government cannot apply
antitrust laws against national
companies in in hell yeah product
inheritor yeah so you start
consolidation with our checks the
relevant information is considered trade
secret
no commercial company is gonna take on
other commercial come within this so it
is left to the educational institutions
most of which are struggling to take one
more breath of air we are in bad shape
so do you think the the motivation then
to do this is is if it's not coming from
the insurer's it's is not the
university's hospital systems have less
time and resources do it where where
does the motivation to create
transparency price transparency come
from from uni I if you get sufficient
strictest this is your this is your um
this is the equation you talk about the
the reform you spell this out for me
previously that reform equals
transparency plus white-hot anger and
that we I mean you really do feel feel
like it requires ordinary people just
get really angry about not having having
enough knowledge about what their own
costs are incurring the cost they are
incurring the little how to channel this
anger ah and by the way of this
something that and always been this
where people talk about we need more
patient involvement you know the joke
about the chicken is involved in an
omelet
that where's the pic had a medical exam
so so um so I want to I want to so given
given your call to transparency I want
to put your I want to put your
enthusiasm your passion for healthcare
in in context so so most people probably
know but maybe it's not not apparent
that they you've actually been involved
in medicine and healthcare for for going
on 20 years going back to your your
funding of prostate research and
parkinson's research the the UCSF
program UCSF UC Berkeley program that
you're doing now this is that this is
actually an industry that you've been
you've had this this frustration and
anger about about how health care is
conducted for a long time I felt like
any soldier whose drafted and it sent
back into another mission I would love
to get out of it battle fatigue that's
right but battling or two because it's
not that these fields are different it
is that these fields are pursued very
similarly hmm and yes sir both of them
is inc allow me to go close to the front
line close to the investigators we can
speak sometimes the same language i
learn all this and i learned that they
are equally frustrated equally
uncomprehending of what is happening for
the throw of the hands and look at the
patient
and do a magnificent job to find that
I'm here to talk to you like that as a
result of a number of very diligent and
capable people doing that and not one of
those would say take and your break is
too much trouble give me my feel and I
interpret for you well now you you so
you've been trying to I mean your
whenever you all of your interest is is
oftentimes in this this environment of
reform so you were trying to change the
way research or you have been trying to
change the way research is done in two
into prostate in parkinson's disease
you've been you've been active in trying
to change the way that that drug
delivery and drug drug research is done
do you when you when you when you put
your finger and you put your mind to one
of these areas do you do you feel like
you've had an influence do you feel like
there's been progress in these areas so
far actually yes hello these two there
are most relevant the most close it time
the way potentially new treatments of
Parkinson's and other brain degenerative
diseases could be a local introduction
to do locus of the damage of a drug
typically conceived to be a protein
growth factor and sort of pump that
substance in the facility desk the
damages the only problem is the brain is
not a homogeneous
material that most of the experiments
have been done the flow the fluid out of
the little pipe can be on even the most
important one is there blood the cells
all over the brain and if you go near
the blood vessel at the flow comes in
the blood vessel is gonna lead the low
away from where you want it to very dirt
on it experimentation was only possible
after MRI around real time to examine
what has happened so we were a
participant in a small group full number
of groups that did work on this one and
I'm pretty proud of what we had done the
second one is simpler Parkinson's is a
movement disorder as our several other
diseases and their rating that is as
necessary for a patient as your test on
big data is for the audience needs to be
made objective common way today is
giving your hand turn it up up and done
a number of times look at your facial
expression on structured data that's a
common comment and it's very inaccurate
right so we have if workforce and
embarrassed to say eight years and
developed an instrument that measures
the irregularities of the move
and of the hand or body so at least one
uncertainty the doctor or nurse rating
is removed this has been a lot of work
and some of the work was because we
never very medicals of my colleagues and
I never worked in medical appears to go
it's just a point of Engineers and some
of it it was physically hard but those
are two that we managed to wrestle into
almost use to amass right well so so
those interesting because those two
examples are so data intensive and so so
such complicated science and and and I
know those efforts both continue but
this idea this idea that you have in the
wire story is is you know one of the
simplest data points right it's very
basic it's just dollars and cents just
trying to make that piece of data that
one piece of data transparent to people
and I i wonder if you think that that
that simplicity is is kind of whether it
is is deceiving and how simplicity and
how simple or apparently simple it might
be is that in fact more complicated
problem do you think then then drug
delivery or some of these research
questions if i get a bill that says we
charge you 100 thousand dollars but
since you are a very nice guy you look
good in your blue shirt or maybe i don't
give you a reason i give you a 95 90
thousand dollar relief so you are you
owe me ten thousand dollars
you have no idea what happened but if
you got ninety thousand dollars you that
are run down the street and inside
everybody who has got ninety thousand
dollars that this saw the old and invite
them to the barricades it will be lonely
so what you do from and that frog enable
the continuation of the economic
behavior of this industry well ND i
think it's a it's a wonderful it's it's
it's wonderful and health care is very
fortunate to have your your clarity of
intellect and your your dedication to
the to these causes so i want to thank
you and and on behalf of everybody here
thank you very much for joining us today
we really appreciated